leur idée politique de base est simple
la loi du plus grand nombre règle d'or
de la démocratie doit s'incliner devant
la loi du meilleur groupe
l'ordre nouveau est parti en guerre
contre le marxisme le gauchisme et
gaulisme c'était hier soir le
rendez-vous de l'extrême droite à la
Mutualité 2500 à 3000 personnes réunies
pour écouter avec ferveur la musique de
Wagner et 3 heures de discours véhément
sous la bannière accroisse celtique des
nationalisme
les mouvements d'extrême droite sont
venus au meeting sous la même bannière
ancien du mouvement dissou-occident
militant de lexoas jeunes étudiants du
groupe Union droit et nationalistes de
tous horizons pendant 15 jours 25000
affiches ont été apposées sur les murs
de Paris par des groupes de jeunes
et pourquoi cette casquette de l'armée
allemande non c'est une casquette qu'on
trouve plus à 5 francs et qui protège
bien la buse
le bastion des idées d'extrême droite
c'est la faculté d'Assas ou cette
implanté fortement le guide le groupe
Union droit ce jour-là l'extrême droite
tenait à SAS ils attendaient les
gauchistes
la terre les gauchistes ont déclenché
plusieurs grèves plusieurs agitations
dans cette faculté et à chaque fois nous
avons contré et ça a payé et petit à
petit nous avons contré leur influence
dans cette faculté petit à petit ils
sont allés de défaite militaires en
défaite politique vous accusé un moment
d'avoir des armes ou d'avoir des
gourdins d'avoir des choses comme ça
AHAs bien sûr c'était tout le monde aime
va nous accuser d'avoir des gourdins des
armes des casques des choses de ce genre
là mais il est bien évident que le jour
où une bagarre se déclenche
il y avait deux casques ici il y a des
gens qui viennent en mobylette tu savais
ils peuvent les laisser là parce que
tous les casques c'est compliqué devant
la fac je crois que pour être honnête le
casque fait partie de du matériel
universitaire
l'affrontement entre étudiant d'extrême
gauche et d'extrême droite le lieu le
lendemain motif l'extrême droite
interdisait l'accès de la faculté un
étudiant israélite membre de la Ligue
communiste la police du intervenu au
bureau politique tous les mouvements
d'extrême droite sont présents nous
avons interrogé leur porte-parole mettre
galvert 33 ans ancien collaborateurs
politiques de maître Tixier Vignancourt
monsieur galvert vous a appelé un 13 mai
nationaliste nationaliste qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire
disons que c'est d'abord l'entité du
gaullisme et du gauchisme du marché
[Musique]
il s'agit de nazis de néofascisme
pour nous c'est beaucoup plus simple peu
à peu il a bien fallu que nous nous
donnions un nom
celui qui nous était offert parce qu'il
restait honorable dégagé toutes les
compromissions c'était celui de
nationaliste pour beaucoup de gens voir
ce qu'ils entendent parler des
nationalisme le mot sonne un peu avec un
accent germanique
pour moi ça me gêne pas certains vous
accusent d'être racistes et antisémite
on pourra nous couvrir un tour de bras
d'un jus en particulier de nous on
pourra nous reprocher d'avoir favorisé
la crémation des juifs pendant la guerre
nous avions pour les plus vieux d'entre
nous quelques trois ans à ce moment-là
un jour nous nous fâcherons un jour nous
font des procès à ces gens-là pour
l'instant les chiens aboient caravane
passe
je crois que c'est d'abord celui de la
jeunesse on prétend que la jeunesse est
désordonnée
qu'elle est révolutionnaire dans tous
les sens qu'elle est explosive c'est pas
vrai
jeunesse est profondément et prise
d'ordre de calme d'organisation
discipline et puis nouveau nouveau parce
que nous déplaise et même nous agace
ceux qui ayant usé leur culotte à tous
les bancs parlementaires aujourd'hui
prétend d'inventer la nouvelle société
[Applaudissements]
leur idée politique de base est simple
la voici telle qu'elle figure dans leur
manifeste la loi du plus grand nombre
règle d'or de la démocratie doit
s'incliner devant la loi du meilleur
groupe
[Musique]